I'll turn it over to Russell or for
questions whether Russ you and James
have both been your team's primary
playmakers for the past seven years how
do you make the balance work one guy off
the ball the other on in interchangeable
or play it out as it goes men Jane's
been friends for many many years since I
was 10 actually uh-huh well yeah we play
with each other for familiars in
Oklahoma City and so to be able to win
something you got a bit of sacrifice
some parts of your game and we both
understand that we both understand that
we have one common goal and that's to
win a championship so we understand what
we have to do almost I'm not worried but
I know James is not worried about it
I can play off the ball I don't have to
touch the bone to impact the game and
that's the best way for me to get a
comeback and impact this team as I I can
do other things on the floor to be able
to make sure we have a better chance to
win it so Ross how would you describe
this opportunity what this means to you
at this point in your career and and to
be able to reunite with James when you
guys go back so far it's amazing
opportunity but I can't you know take on
the next journey without thinking you
know Oklahoma City Thunder Sam mr.
Bennett the whole Thunder organization's
just for taking me and drafting me it's
something that I never would have
thought of being there and being able to
now come and reunite here with James
another great chapter in my life and I'm
looking forward to what comes from that
what about this opportunity excites you
to excite you the most she's better with
a championship I think I have a great
organization here great group of guys
great for an office great coaching as
well and I think it's a great
opportunity to be able to bring a
championship here to Houston opportunity
and be able to do great things have some
fun and I'm excited for today and
network with every opportunity comes
goals and challenges what are your goals
here in Houston and most important what
are your challenges to come here to
Houston our one goal is to win the
championship and I think we start a
season that's everybody's goal but
obviously here and something that we
want to do is something that we gonna
take the time and put the work in to be
able to do that some of the challenges I
think just early on just figuring out
know myself figuring out some of the
guys guys freaking me out
coaching staff and I think all that is
growing pains but it's not nothing that
myself were a word about and hope the
team is not worried about neither russa
this rockets team has been playing a
certain style for a long long time a lot
of threes the shoot attacking the basket
spread the floor as well on defense they
switch a lot how do you see yourself
fitting into that and how do you see
possibly changes that you could make to
the to that style
um I fit right in personally I'm able to
the floor spray it gives me a good
opportunity to be able to attack
penetrate kick defensively give you an
opportunity to be able to switch and
guard and rebound at a high level push
to break gets us out on a break a lot of
different things in my opinion I think
the style of players is great and
something I'm looking forward to just in
getting our space and open the floor
shooters all around and playing that way
hey Russell can you talk about just the
process of oh there you go sir I'm in
the back from when you first even
thought you could come to Houston and
just seemed to happen pretty quickly but
can you talk about the process and how
that was how it was being a part of that
oh it's a crazy process honestly but it
was a collaborative effort it was a
process that you know obviously came
very very quickly but um I thought it
was the best decision for me and my
career right now and be able to reunite
you know with a brother a friend and to
be able to do that it's something that
you dream about and you live for and
there's something that was exciting to
me Russ right here yeah how would you
say that you and James complement each
other
you guys were primary ball handlers the
last few years so you guys have played
in a certain system and things like that
so when you come here what will each of
you do to complement one another
I think we play great off the ball
together with each other we've done it
in Oklahoma City and there's been many
times in Oklahoma City when James on the
team he closed the game with the primary
ball and I played off the ball we're
just totally fine for me because like I
said before I am offensively and scoring
and having the ball in my hands is not
the only thing I can do for the game I
do a lot of great things for the game
and I look forward to doing that with
this team as well outside of a plane
with mr. Harden what else I mean what
other players on this roster enticed you
or wanted to make you want to come to
play for the Houston Rockets every
single one of them I've been battling
for playoffs many many years so I know
the guys very well know the person know
very well and but tough I don't think we
beat the Rockets in a series may be
shaken so that means their first year
before we also the roster very very well
and the guys here compliment the game
and do a lot of great things for the
game and I'm just here to be able to
help those guys out here arrests have
you had much time to chat with Dan
tonyia and if so what do you think about
him and playing with him and moving
forward with him uh yeah definitely I
had a opportunity to be able to sit down
and talk to him a little bit I've been
North Coast D'Antoni
since the USA basketball so I kind of
kind of great relationship with him and
we talked about a few things nothing
into debt but we'll definitely sit down
and be able to have a conversation no
moving for rusty right when you look
around the NBA and this offseason seemed
to be a lot of movement with star level
players what is your analysis of all of
the movement and how the new team stack
up I only care about one team and that's
the Houston Rockets everybody else
it's not in my worries it's not our
worry and something that we know worried
about we know we capable of doing here
and that's how we worry about Russ back
here in the back I see how big of a when
this all this process came about and you
decide you know realize
that the trade was possible how big of a
role did James play in and selling
Houston to you a huge room you know
James is persistent if he wants
something done and you know we
conversating intelligence about getting
things done and you know we had
conversations and we always talked about
the season so it was definitely a
process and easy process of me and not a
hard decision at all you guys said it
came together quickly I didn't have been
quick enough for James Russell right
here in front of us
deshaun Watson the quarterback of the
Texans we asked him about you yesterday
I want to read you what he said all
right he said I'm a Westbrook fan I've
been a fan since I was a little kid I
love his energy
I love his mentality I love what he
brings to the table each and every game
he's a guy I can look up to the way he
plays every night I can do for myself
I'm definitely going to be at the games
for sure front row when I said that to
me that's a blessing always you know I'm
a fan of heads as well and you know I
think it's a for me and so it's a honor
and a blessing to be able to hear
another athlete another person in
general to be able to say they look up
to me and the things I'm able to do and
I don't take that for granted and just
motivates me to be able to come out and
do the same thing every night at a high
level and figuring out a way to be able
to stay consistent throughout the season
each and every player what about playing
with guys like PJ Tucker and Eric Gordon
love those guys do their job at a very
very high level going to compete and
whenever you have guys that compete
every single night that's all you can
ask for the basketball self missing and
making shots is a part of the game but
they go out and compete at a high level
that's emotion connect for question for
Darryl you mentioned the Hall of Fame
back of you obviously all the Famer we
all understand that the bearing him with
James how would you describe what he's
gonna bring to this team in terms of
will to win emptying the tank on the
floor night in and night out of what
effect will that have on your team I
think people have seen him play we
talked about all the wars we've had and
obviously they got the better of us at
the end of the season with a big play
to hurt us a little bit so it's good to
add him I mean he plays with an energy a
passion a will the win I think is really
unparalleled in the league you know
that's gonna be huge for us and
transition on the defensive end you know
James Harden played with him before but
when he was on not on the Rockets I
asked about him and he said like he's
relentless he comes constantly he
doesn't seem to get tired it's
intimidating to the opponents how how
much passion he brings to the game and
to have that on our bench now is is
incredible
there when did you know that this trade
was possible and you just speak to what
it took to get it done I mean we didn't
think I was possible till the movement
happened with with Paul George and you
know obviously such a cornerstone of
that franchise we had never expected
something like this could happen but
once it did happen it was a pretty quick
discussion with ownership and James
Harden and and we knew this was
something we had to get done if we could
Russell you mentioned all your time in
Oklahoma City changing cities as well
moving you know come in to Houston
big city with the Texans and the Astros
and so many other stars would have been
your thoughts about the city of Houston
thus far and just the opportunity being
in the city presents for you it's hot as
hell no it's been great getting getting
acclimated and figuring out a way to get
the family settled in and I'm looking
forward to it obviously it's a different
change but growing up in LA and kind of
said we been a big city and then living
there in the summertime but planning one
is definitely different and it's gonna
be something I look forward to and you
know it's exciting for free agents out
there it's 75 degrees all summer's a
little hot Russell along those lines
you've spent so much time in Oklahoma
City became so identified with the
franchise and the city what are the
emotions from that temple just of
leaving that stuff behind oh I mean it's
tough man it wasn't something that will
stay with me the rest of my life because
I basically grew up there in Oklahoma
City
18 17 years old and in Oklahoma City in
them the people the organization have
never done me wrong they always stood up
for me and my family and I always had my
back and I'm very very grateful and I
don't take that for granted and like I
said Sam and mr. Bennett and coach
Brooks goes Donovan the whole staff
everybody over there they always have my
best interest in I can do nothing but be
thankful and be grateful to what they
did for me my family a rush you
mentioned you know this team who are the
guys on the team right now that you
played with or are looking forward to
playing with play with um not
necessarily play with but I mean you've
been the league so long you understand
well guys do you understand what the
cable are doing and I'm here to help you
know I'm here to bring extra kind of
guys to bring extra out of my teammates
maybe they can help me out I'm always
looking at a final way to be able to be
improving my game as well and prove
something and add something to my game
and I'm just looking forward to the
overall experience